daryl bibi is attracting attention
lately all because of one accessory on
his pickup truck that's what this flag
has come to symbolize as our right as
canadians to choose bibi chose to drive
his truck in the edmonton protest this
weekend flying the maple leaf to show
support for the protest turned
occupation in ottawa several times
during our interview passing motorists
showed support for him
anybody flying a flag off the truck
right now
it's like a harley owners group or
something that's not how everyone
chooses to see it in fact a canadian
flag flying from a truck or semi right
now can produce a completely different
reaction
i don't think it changes my perception
of the flag but i definitely
have some preconceived ideas of the
people who fly them when i see it
mackenzie hayne wonders if anyone will
make assumptions about the flag outside
her house there long before it was tied
to large-scale protests we thought that
it was a good idea a good symbol of
nationalism
but i want it to stay a symbol of
nationalism and not necessarily a
political belief it wouldn't be the
first time the maple leaf has been
associated with polarizing sentiment
this canada-themed souvenir store says
it's seen a boost in sales recently
mainly from flags owner joe nicolette
believes it's driven by pride not
politics with a store like myself i
don't get political i stay away from
that type of thing
is this not political though these hats
these were made
for for a customer that wanted to show
some support for the convoy how long are
you going to fly the flag on the back
you truck
until the convoy pulls back out of
ottawa
however you feel about bibi's truck flag
the reactions are a reflection of a
polarized nation where a path to unity
doesn't appear so red and white
dan grumman global news